hello and welcome to this video playing
mysterious expert lme chess master right
some internal leeches title not
something official by freedom or any
other organization so we have a like a
ready double fianchetto style position
yeah why does very slightly for choice
him but it is not much a bit surprised
what this is here at the airport that's
really great
i wonder if at the end isn't that more
weakness than anything else interesting
so he takes down what is still looking
for here i mean this is just a very very
comfortable structure for white i just
have more central control it looks looks
odd okay I can go it's sour good yeah
even this is a good square keeping
pressure on b7
I don't want to trade he's got too many
pieces for this position blacks position
would be completely okay if he would
have like one minor piece but it's got
four thought so I applied age six no
Bishop g4 please okay now you can think
of a d5 trying to immediately blow black
world blow black out of the water
blue black that's a tough one yeah I
look strong right what is what is this
reply h5 already wreaked of desperation
a little bit okay now I got Bishop e5 as
a move but doesn't do much
Knight e5 is also a possibility it looks
like he puts the most pressure on him I
guess I can also take which is not bad
let's go 95 and maybe he's got Knight
takes d5 now I'm okay it's probably
better for white but not I can take b7
okay
okay now just Bishop h6 maybe where I
can go and form and it wasn't intended
but now I can just take on c6 yeah let's
do it
what take on c6 immediately it doesn't
make a huge difference I guess I maybe
maybe take the difference maybe has 65
no I could creamy - okay
here if five should work should work I
mean would be nice if it worked but just
have this one as well
so anyway for him to pin me on six
probably not 95 maybe
you know I mean that is a that is okay
now 94 maybe one say anything better an
idea form should be fine
Jim no no maybe I had something better
but that is definitely okay yeah I keep
that pawn and my threat was Bishop e7 I
am 93 maybe I should have played that
differently but okay he's called a
knight on b8 so
195 hmm I didn't see Knight f5 I should
have taken that into consideration
[Music]
play formate it doesn't stop the maid
a position out of the opening looked
basically unplayable yeah yeah I'm
already quite happy I don't think this
is the best possible setup but it's it's
still not terrible for black but it gets
a bit odd around here I don't like what
he's doing now so the engine actually
dislikes my move before I'd wants to
play efore with a good position and it
doesn't like this one
due to this smooth it's surprising I
mean it's it's absolutely
I don't think I don't think white can be
worse yeah it's kind of weird I mean I I
would be I would concede that this could
be equal but blackest can never be
better that's just not happening
okay but black is fine that's true so he
took here no yeah this is probably once
I get dissing I think I'm very happy and
this is a very good central construction
and I'm preventing e5 and so it looks
very nice
okay here I already had d5 yeah that was
better
h3 was yeah unnecessary prophylaxis that
same age 5 then I went d5 yeah it's
pretty much fine and now I should have
taken about 97 a second also completely
winning so it was okay up to this point
and now I made mistakes
so f4 wasn't right I kind of suspected
that but yeah when you have to make
moves aged form
yeah so II five would have aged syphilis
four plus two I'm sorry even here yeah
okay now it'd be 85 and now Queen d2 was
winning the Queen okay or the house yeah
that is a lot stronger really so this is
the blunder it still keeps the win but
so this is winning yeah I mean that is
not really great damn okay so I went
into a winning ending instead instead of
checkmating well it's just a very good
position that is probably not the best
but it just it is enough just have too
many problems in Rebecca yeah if I runs
into the maid but okay it's it's just
completely lost interesting yeah that
this is 95 was so so bad
this is still okay it's probably really
necessary that he's got a three here too
to simply make sure that this is an
isolated pawn and that is not covered
anymore that is a big difference okay
guys thanks for watching